this is one of the world's fastest
self-propelled sport
[Music]
the fastest skater will go over 50
kilometers per hour
to travel at such a high pace on the
eyes it feels that i can never get this
kind of feeling anywhere else
my name is lucas ang and i'm a short
track speed skater i have been skating
for over 20 years but competitively only
the reason 45 years
i compete with singapore but i'm right
now training in south korea
[Applause]
back in singapore a tropical country we
only have one ice rink and it's a public
ring so we only get two times of ice a
week whereas here in south korea i get
two times of ice in one day
i really like the culture of the people
here and how the whole system in the
sporting environment is
it allows me to understand the spot
better training alongside the koreans
who are the top athletes in this sport
as well
we train almost six to seven days a week
about five six hours a day pretty much
like a full-time job
it is quite a physical demanding spot
we'll do speed training we'll do
interval training we imitate the actions
and the movements on eyes and then we do
it on land so that we strengthen
the muscles needed
when i'm skating on ice it's
a moment where i feel that i'm in my own
world
it feels that i have a lot of focus and
it's me and myself against the eyes and
against the speed that i'm trying to
achieve
[Music]
i'm happy to have come so far and to
have met all the great people in the
sport
and personally i feel that every time i
train and compete it makes me have this
adrenaline to want to work harder to
want to achieve greater
and not give up
[Music]